alors à qui s'adresse cette prison
charge pour quelle pathologie et à quel
prix on fait le point avec notre invité
du jour
Sarah Lombardi bonjour bonjour vous êtes
donc sage-femme coordinatrice de la SADE
achat des pédiatries en Indre-et-Loire
expliquez-nous d'abord pourquoi est-ce
que la prise en charge des enfants à
leur domicile elle n'était pas possible
auparavant en fait auparavant elle était
possible mais très rarement et surtout
avec une équipe
d'infirmières qui étaient plutôt
spécialisée chez les adultes et là
depuis le mois de juin on a mis en place
une équipe dédiée avec des infirmières
puéricultrices ou en tout cas avec une
expérience pédiatrique exclusivement qui
vont prendre ses enfants spécialement en
charge d'accord dans quel cas est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui on propose l'achat des
pédiatriques alors on propose ça peut
être pour un nouveau-né qui sort de
maternité mais effectivement comme vous
avez dit dans le dans le reportage ça
peut être jusqu'à la majorité
c'est des prises en charge en fait pour
tout soin hospitaliers qui peuvent se
faire à la maison donc ça va d'une
surveillance de poids
ou d'une jaunisse chez un nouveau-né
mais ça peut ça peut aussi aller jusqu'à
une alimentation avec une sonde domicile
besoin d'oxygène à domicile ou bien des
traitements par voie intraveineuse par
exemple comme des antibiotiques est-ce
que ça peut être à la demande des
parents où ça marche pas comme ça alors
les parents peuvent en parler à leur
médecin s'ils en ont entendu parler
effectivement mais pour rentrer en
hospitalisation à domicile il faut une
prescription médicale donc c'est avec un
médecin traitant un médecin d'un service
hospitalier ou bien un pédiatre qui me
fait la demande est-ce que est-ce qu'il
y a un coût supplémentaire pour les
parents est-ce que c'est plus cher ou
est-ce que c'est moins cher que
l'hospitalisation classique alors il y a
pas de coût pour les parents c'est une
prise en charge par la Sécurité Sociale
et si après il y a un petit surcoût
c'est la mutuelle qui prennent le relais
il faut savoir qu'une hospitalisation
classique à l'hôpital c'est entre 1000
euros et 1500 euros par jour
puisque ça englobe effectivement tout le
personnel et tout ce qui va avec
l'hospitalisation à domicile ça coûte
entre 200 et 300 euros donc il y a quand
même une nette
réduction de coûts parce que tout
simplement on est chez soi c'est notre
électricité on mange chez soi c'est plus
facile tout à fait voilà et à domicile
c'est l'intervention donc d'infirmières
on peut avoir un médecin si besoin aussi
et puis il faut savoir qu'à l'achat des
on a aussi toute une équipe
pluridisciplinaire avec des psychologues
aussi des assistantes sociales qui
peuvent voilà intervenir ses besoins
l'objectif c'est aussi de laisser tes
places pour des cas plus graves des
engorger l'hôpital tout à fait alors
après on intervient déjà sur le Loiret
et sur l'Eure-et-Loir avec du Nasha des
pédiatriques et donc ça nous est arrivé
d'intervenir par exemple cet hiver quand
il y avait les bronchiolites qui
engorgeaient tous les services de
pédiatrie au niveau de l'hôpital
d'Orléans ça nous a permis en fait de
libérer des places pour ces
bronchiolites qui arrivaient à l'hôpital
est-ce que le fait d'être chez lui dans
son dans son environnement peut aussi
concourir à ce que l'enfant guérisse
plus vite ou qu'ils se sentent mieux
alors ça c'est évident
on a déjà pu observer qu'un par exemple
un prématuré qui passe déjà deux mois et
demi trois mois de sa vie à l'hôpital à
un moment donné il peut stagner au
niveau de la prise de poids et le fait
de rentrer à domicile les parents sont
plus sereins l'enfant aussi et on voit
bien que la courbe de poids décolle
c'est sûr qu'à domicile les parents déjà
sont chez eux ils font pas les
déplacements à l'hôpital pour aller pour
rester auprès de leurs enfants il y a la
fratrie aussi qui peut du coup être
aussi présente autour de cet enfant et
puis les aides supplémentaires comme les
grands-parents les amis et voilà
aujourd'hui est-ce que quelle est la
capacité j'allais dire d'accueil
d'action de l'achat d'achat des alors en
fait on n'a pas un nombre de lit limités
comme à l'hôpital
on intervient donc sur tout le
territoire d'Indre-et-Loire sur tout le
37 donc après c'est pas en termes de lit
ça va plutôt être en termes
de soins à réaliser au domicile et puis
aussi de distance parce que c'est sûr
que si on prend plusieurs patients très
éloignés il faut aussi prendre en compte
le temps de route il y a des choses
qu'on est-ce qu'on peut tout faire à
domicile alors quand même à domicile on
n'est pas des soins de d'urgence ni de
réanimation donc clairement non
vous disiez une chimiothérapie c'est
possible de faire à domicile
effectivement il faut savoir qu'on a des
conventions avec des pharmacies avec la
pharmacie hospitalière si c'est vraiment
un produit qui doit sortir de l'hôpital
et ça effectivement ça se met en place
il y a pas de pas de souci quoi comment
faire du coup on passe par son médecin
traitant
si on est à l'hôpital c'est le service
qui nous appelle directement et puis le
plus de la de l'achat des c'est que en
24 heures sur 24 il y a des astreintes
téléphoniques
infirmier et médecin qui permet vraiment
d'avoir une continuité de soin tous les
jours 7 jours sur 7 on m'écoutez merci
Sarah Lombardi pour cet éclairage sur
l'hospitalisation à domicile des enfants